how close are we now  Steve that's you 45-second this is death  no no no we have that in the segment  which part this is dead oh this is dead  people watching TV love to hear a guy  looking to the Cabaret this is that that  kills in the Midwest what are you  talking about people just switch the  channel I know I've never done that I  haven't done that in all my years on the  air but tonight you know this is a  worthwhile thing to do what time are we  getting there  what's it okay it's now 11:30 five holes  record us but switch today  [Applause]  okay they're gone now  they're gone now now we can do whatever  though  [Applause]  well gave what a legacy what a legacy  day what you've been fired  Thanks  [Applause]